Resident Evil the final chapter is
directed by Paul WS Anderson and starts
his wife Melia vivec and is being
marketed as the last one will ever have
to see in theaters one can only hope now
a quick glance behind me should inform
you that I really like Resident Evil
I've been a big fan of the game series
ever since the first one I've loved
almost every single one of them save for
five and six and a couple of small
spin-offs I'm a huge fan of the games
but unfortunately we live in a world
where if you say I'm a fan of Resident
Evil you are forced to distinguish
yourself between some of the shittiest
video game movies ever made and some of
the best survival horror games ever made
because these movies pretty much all
suck now I just have one question for
you
are you already on board with the
Resident Evil movies have you seen all
of them up until now and been like yeah
I'm excited for the final chapter I like
these movies I don't get to hate then
just go see it you don't give a shit
about what critics have to say about
this movie you're going to like it just
just go watch it for all the rest of us
this was one of the most insufferable
films I've seen in a theater in recent
memory let's get into everything about
this film that I absolutely hated and
there's quite a bit but first off oh
yeah there's a plot Emilia yova bitch
she plays Alice she's an ass-kicking
person who never dies and there's a
bunch of zombies because the umbrella
corporation unleashed the t-virus and so
she's gotta kill them that's the plot
maybe this film will actually clear up
15 long years of continuity errors of a
franchise that makes no sense anymore or
maybe it'll just be a bunch of mindless
action scenes I'm going with the ladder
this film begins with a summary of
everything else that happened in the
other movies just in case no one saw
them that's right this film has a last
time on Resident Evil Melia Jovovich
punched a lot of zombies and Paul WS
Anderson can't direct worth shit find
out what happens to Alice put a on
Resident Evil the final shit Bach
as this movie begins it became
incredibly clear that Paul WS Anderson
saw Mad Max fury road and thought hey
that was awesome let's make the last one
look like that because the first 15 to
20 minutes of this movie is the biggest
Mad Max ripoff I've seen he tries to
emulate this incredibly rapid editing
style this fierce visual style that
George Miller pioneered so well and he
just comes off like a little
kindergartner who saw an older kid in
high school and said I'll I'd be like
him
hey mom you can join a basketball team
cuz look at that guy he's so cool you're
five years old shut the fuck up kid hey
you can't say those words to me I want
to be like the cool guys yeah well you
got no talent well that's okay because
my movies make their budget back why are
you saying you make movies you're five
years old
shut up mommy I'm a director and for the
first 30 minutes of this movie you're
bombarded with jump-scare after jump
scare after jump scare which really took
me off guard because I didn't think this
movie would be like that I was just
expecting some mindless action sequences
but every other minute it seems like
Alice just stops walking somewhere looks
around all the sound drains out and then
some zombie comes out and this big
over-the-top noise and I thought okay
maybe that's just like the first act
maybe they're just going to do that a
few times no it really extends beyond
that 30 minutes and into the entire film
this endless series of moments where the
sound drowns out and then a zombie just
pops out and you're supposed to be
scared by this but it's so ear piercing
ly loud and annoying and absurd that it
just gets old after 10 minutes in fact
I'm sorry look it it's old already
this film is filled with so many tired
manipulative ways of editing a film
together which we'll talk about a little
bit more in detail in a second that it
was old from the first time it happened
jump scares they're gone guys so let's
talk about that editing like I just said
this is some of the worst I've seen in a
big-budget movie and
Theatre in my entire life I swear to you
the median shot length is less than a
second it's got to be it has to be
there's one sequence where she takes two
guns and she's facing off against a bio
weapon it's this big-ass thing that
looks like the abomination from The
Incredible Hulk and she's just shooting
at it and it's running towards her and
the way he cut back and forth between
these moments was so mind-numbing and so
my grayned inducing especially in 3d
which is how I saw this movie that I
almost got up and left I almost left I
almost walked out of this movie because
I was so genuinely offended by how this
film was cut together the fact that a
bunch of people came together and went
yeah yeah that's good we like it well
sign off on it have millions of dollars
enjoy your penthouse I'm really not
selling this enough my point needs to be
made this editing is some of the worst
top 5 I've ever seen in a movie the
action sequences in this film are so
terrifically disgusting looking they're
so ugly and horribly choreographed you
can't tell what's going on at all
there's a sequence in this movie where a
character dies I had no idea who died
it's a big sequence with a fan look out
for it I had to wait to the next scene
for him to cut back and forth between
the principal characters to figure out
who just died that's how bad it is it
feels like the director and the editor
took an infant into the room and said
here's a keyboard play around with it
any point okay I like this keyboard oh
this is fun I like button oh boy and
that's how the film got edited that's my
best that's the only way that it makes
sense in my mind beyond that I have no
idea what they were thinking this film
is also trying extremely hard to force a
completely unearned sense of finality
the music and the pseudo badassery
that's cut together in a way that's so
manipulative to make you think that
something amazing just happened it all
is - hammer
own the point that this is the last one
this is the big one where all of our
questions will be answered and we'll
have this amazing experience where
everything is so exciting and
world-ending
but it's just an endless series of
action scenes cut together with an
exposition scene and that's how the
entire film plays out big mindless
action scene cut together an absolute
shift and in an exposition scene where
everyone stands around in a circle and
somebody tells them a story have been
another mindlessly horribly edited
action scene exposition action
exposition action that's this film I
really want to know if the actors and
the crew people who read this script and
got together to make this movie thought
wow I can't wait to take part in this
project this is going to be awesome or
were they like oh good I can pay my rent
for another year there is one moment in
this movie that I could pinpoint is
being effective a truck goes beneath an
underpass and there are three zombies
that are hanging at the neck and they
just kind of go ahead and come to life
for a second and try to grab at the
truck and I was like that's that's some
creepy imagery that's it everything else
is shit like garbage pit trash shit like
the little bacteria that that's lining
the bottom of your trash can that's
Resident Evil final chapter there's a
part in the movie where outlets just
kind of shows up at this compound that's
apparently led by other people and
there's a big army of zombies coming and
she just takes over as leader no
questions asked people are like who's
that girl who cares ally larders in the
film and she knows who Alison Zoe she's
the leader now yay
that's how the script works Alice
doesn't do anything to earn her title of
badass action hero she just is and she
does things and she punches things she
doesn't do anything that people like
look at and go wow she really is earned
this title she's just this vessel that
can shoot and kill a billion zombies and
that's it she's essentially any one of
us that grabs the two fake plastic guns
in a light arcade game like House of the
Dead in a movie theater and shoot
the zombies as they come towards them
that's all she is she's the worst
fucking character for this movie and I'm
such a big fan of these games I would
love if they could actually just be like
hey all that shit didn't happen all
those movies that shat all over a great
video game franchise just completely
forget about them let's reboot this and
have a truly scary movie that takes
place in a mansion or something and just
forget about all this sci-fi matrix
ripoff Mad Max fury road ripoff bullshit
let's talk about some of the special
effects in this movie there's a sequence
in cryogenic storage that looks like
someone bought a green-screen off of
Amazon for $20 and is testing it out for
the first time it's really that bad
people I'm sitting in this theater
staring at this screen wearing these 3d
glasses it's causing my eyes to bleed
out of my face looking at this movie
wondering did someone just put this
together on Adobe After Effects straight
out of high school and somehow got some
budget behind it the film even has one
final fuck you two fans of this
franchise people who have been enjoying
these films for 15 years it has the most
absurd pointless unnecessary final twist
I won't get into it but it completely
dishonours the main character and every
film before this one is now affected by
it it can't even cater to longtime fans
who have stuck with this shit for as
long as they have as I said the main
hero in this movie she does nothing to
earn this title of amazing badass hero
she even detonates a bomb inches away
from the very thing that she is trying
to protect with no thoughts about the
repercussions of this but of course
everything's fine because it's Paul WS
Anderson who wrote the screenplay and
without spoiling anything the ending
makes no sense geographically what
happens makes no sense a character falls
down we'll put it that way a character
just kind of falls over and then later
you're like why did you fall over to add
some extra draw
in there at the last second nothing in
this film makes sense the special
effects are atrocious the acting what
acting
there's no acting that action is shot to
such unbelievable shit and cut together
in such a horrible way to give you a
migraine I can't believe these films
have lasted as long as they have
Resident Evil the final chapter just
might be my least favorite in the entire
saga I don't care it's awful I hated
every minute of it
do yourself a favor if you've never seen
these movies play the games they're
worth your time they're fun they
actually give you a good experience they
actually leave you feeling like okay I
just invested time in something and it
was actually worth it I'm going to give
Resident Evil the final fucking blow and
ass on a happy note I'm going to be
ending my matrix series of reviews on
Sunday with the Animatrix and I'm still
going to go see the Matthew McConaughey
film gold I'll have a review up for you
very soon for that guys thank you so
much as always for watching if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]